>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
HARRIS IS NOT SUGGESTING THE
MASSES GO OPIATES.
CALIFORNIA IS FAILING FAST.
WHERE ONLY IMMIGRANT AND WEALTHY
TECH BARONS FEEL VEHICLE.
HYGIENE IS AN ISSUE.
AND OFFICIAL OUTBREAK OF
HYPOTHETICAL A IT IS
A NECESSITY.
SHOT BY A RECENT FELLOP WHO WAS
SHIELDED BY THE SANCTUARY
POLICY.
STENCH OF URINE AND FESES IS
TRONNING.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA TENT
CITY.
>> THEY WOULD HAVE ARRESTED MORE
IMMIGRANT BUT OAKLAND'S MAYOR
ISSUED A AT THE SAME TIME AND
WARNED OF THE RAIDS.
>> Tucker: CALIFORNIA MATTERS.
VICTOR IS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE STATE AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
YOU DESCRIBED THE ECONOMIC
DISTRIBUTION OF CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY HAS MED I CAN'T HAVAL
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IT MEANS 75 PERCENT OF THE
DPSHGS -- GEOGRAPHICAL PEOPLE.
AND COASTAL CORRIDOR WHERE WE
CAL- TECH AND STANFORD AND 3
TRILLION IN CAPITALIZED SILICON
COMPANY AND THIS IS WHERE ALL OF
THE POLICY IS MADE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE IT.
LAWYERS AND ACADEMICS AND
POLITICIANS ARE NEVER SUBJECT OF
THE RAMIFICATIONS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SUCH WELT.
CALIFORNIA IS A MEDEVIAL SOCIETY
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
BASKET OF GASOLINE SALES AND
RANK 49 OR 45 IN SCHOOL.
AND HIGHEST KILOWATT.
AND WILL GASOLINE IS THE HIGH OF
THE.
AND IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE PEOPLE
MAKING THE REGULATION.
WHERE I WORK AT STANFORD.
IT IS 75 OR 65 DEGREES.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TURN ON THE
HEATER OR AIR CONDITIONING.
BUT IN THE VALLEY.
POOR PEOPLE GO TO WALMART
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T TURN ON THE
AIR CONDITIONING.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN WATER FOR
THE AGRICULTURE.
BUT THEY DO IN ARCHITECTURE.
AND THAT REVERBATES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT IS
DYSFUNCTIONAM SAY THE.
MIDDLE-CLASS, 4- 5 PEOPLE LEFT.
AND 4- 5 PEOPLE COME ILLEGALLY
FROM SOUTHERN MEXICO AND GLOBAL
WEALTH IN A SMALL AREA.
AND YOU PUT THAT TOGETHER.
AND YOU GET WHAT YOU HAVE NOW.
>> Tucker: IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.